was genau weiß man jetzt schon darüber
wie es dazu kommen konnte ist der
vierjährige von dem zug erfasst worden
ist ja von zu hause weggelaufen seine
eltern ihn gesucht was weiß man sonst
noch für details jetzt man weiß
mittlerweile dass er mit seiner familie
in einer kleingartenanlage hier in
gardelegen gefeiert gespielt hat die
kleingartenanlage so findet sich hinter
mir
in unserer nähe der bahnanlage die
familie die eltern die drei kinder drei
jungs haben waren zu besuch in
gardelegen die mutter stammt aus diesem
ort hier in der altmark und der junge
kannte also auch die gegend musste dass
hier die züge kommen und mittlerweile
weiß die polizei dass er alleine weg
gelaufen ist und offensichtlich zu dem
teil der bahnschienen gelaufen ist die
nicht durch einen schutzwall geschützt
sind seien große strecken der bahnanlage
hier in gardelegen sind beiden seiten
ich kann das im hintergrund erkennen mit
einem schutzwall ausgestattet der junge
so viel ist sicher war nicht obenauf
begleiten aber auch in abstand weitesten
polizei sprach von rund fünf metern
reicht die kraft ist es den jungen
hochzuziehen
man geht also davon aus dass wir
möglicherweise hier züge angucken wollte
alleine und besonders tragisch die
eltern haben ihn gesucht was passiert
das ist eine schöne gegend ihre joggen
leute lang erfahren fahrradfahrer lang
ist im zeltweger es ist kein keine lange
strecke man hat also nicht sofort
bemerkt dass er weg war und
offensichtlich das hat sich im nachgang
auch ausgestellt war ja früher schon
öfter mit verwandten und hat sich hier
züge angeguckt und wollten das
offensichtlich vielleicht alleine tun